[Music]
with the release of this false Joker
strong Joaquin Phoenix will see the
debut of the latest skeptical take on
one of the most iconic comic book super
villains ever created but believe it or
not it turns out that Phoenix could have
been cast in the role of a completely
different legendary bad guy not for DC
but for Marvel
that's the word according to Charlie
when former head of visual development
for Marvel Studios and the guy who led
the team in charge of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe his whole visual
design he may have heard that Phoenix
famously turned down the role of Doctor
Strange back in 2014 a part that
eventually went to Benedict Cumberbatch
but before that he was also one of the
Hollywood a-listers to audition for the
role of the Red Skull in 2011's Captain
America the First Avenger according to
when who tells us that he had created a
couple versions of Phoenix in the role
the actor quote definitely could have
added a quirky creepy feel to Red Skull
if you're wondering about just what
Phoenix as a Red Skull would have looked
like at least while a comic-book villain
still wore his human skin look no
further than the exclusive concept arts
when provided to looper one thing that
stands out in this image immediately is
Phoenix's youth about 14 years younger
than Hugo Weaving Phoenix as a Red Skull
it would have been much close to an age
to Chris Evans as Captain America what a
closer age gap have made a difference to
how it felt to watch Captain America
beat up the red skull thus a red skull
need to be older and have a claim on
more wisdom and experience and cap to be
more convincingly threatening maybe then
again maybe not but more important than
all that it's not hard to see that when
captured Phoenix is quiet intensity
pretty easily in his mock-up the look in
his eyes clearly communicates the kind
of authoritarian lunacy I could only
radiate off of the leader of Hydra hail
Hydra
it's really fun to imagine how Phoenix's
hyper-focused take on the Red Skull
might have affected the overall film
however when points south are such an
intense villain might not have actually
served the film very well as a whole I
think he would probably have stood out
more than was called for in that role
Hugo Weaving on the other hand brought
us all to red skull that was pretty much
just right for the story at the time and
for where Marvel was at that point in
the MCU one that isn't making too large
of a statement for the role that makes
sense when you think about it
Captain America the First Avenger is a
period piece an origin story a family
friendly war movie an adventure film and
two sets up for one of the biggest
crossover films the Avengers ever made
up to that point weavings turn as a
[ __ ] evil supervillain slots
imperfectly providing just enough bad
guy charm to keep things moving along
and never distracting too much from the
movies various missions meanwhile
Joaquin Phoenix could have very well
stolen the show that'd be great for the
actor but maybe not so awesome for the
Avengers which needed to have audiences
already rooting for Captain America by
the time he first shows up on screen in
the modern age I gotta say it's an honor
to meet you officially I sort of met you
I mean I watched you while you were
sleeping
so while we could mourn the Red Skull we
never got we might be better off getting
excited for the Joker we will have by
the end of the year with just a few
photos and one trailer Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker directed by Todd Phillips has
gotten tons of fans buzzing poke around
on the internet for just a few minutes
and you'll see no shortage of hot takes
saying that Phoenix's Joker has a
potential to outshine even Heath
Ledger's legendary Turner's a villain
when for his part to grease the world of
the Dark Knight's been established as a
much darker take on comic book
storytelling and again one that is
perfect for both Batman and the Joker
Phoenix is one of the few a-list actors
I can see possibly living up to the
iconic Joker that Heath Ledger gave us
overall when thinks the world is much
better off for Phoenix putting a stamp
on the Joker explaining I think he's
perfect for the current Joker film that
is in he's such a fantastic character
actor check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite supervillains are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]